so
so um then he says hey um i see that
you're interested in ping pong
and i really want to help you so i want
to pay for you to go to germany
and i was like what now the only thing i
knew about germany was hitler
so i was like i was like i was like this
is just getting worse and worse
as it goes along germany and but but
still i was always a person that i
jumped on opportunity
right it didn't matter it was good or
bad if it was opportunity i'm taking it
right because i never know
what was different uncharted territory
is scary jeremy it's a different country
yeah whoa was crazy and you were how old
at the time i was let me see when he
said the germany
is 14 16. 18. okay yeah so so i was like
whoa man
really so yeah man the dude made it
happen did he had a connection and
i didn't know any of this i know he had
a connection to
all this stuff he never told me any of
this stuff and so he had a connection
with a sports school in germany
and in hanover the town is called
hanover and uh
in that school is where all the uh
top athletes of different sports live
right so their curriculum is mostly
their sport and then the academics is
secondary this is like the top level
so i i went there and i lived with these
kids
for like two months and uh learned
ping-pong and
that's how i started that's really
[ __ ] cool how they make the people
that are really good at their sports
yeah the primary thing
primary thing an academic secondary yeah
when in america they pretend like it's
the other way around exactly pretend
here like academics comes first but
really
we know the real deal right exactly yeah
but which is stupid that we do that
it's crazy it's crazy because like you
know like like all these kids
they they're like the top in in their in
their city
what whether it was a a a table tennis
or or or tennis or or soccer that
they were the top in their city so they
all go to the school they all live
together
in this school they all practice their
sport they all eat together
you know it was really it's really
interesting what kind what kind of
different sports were they there
uh so if i remember correctly there was
a table tennis
i think there was uh basketball there
was uh
football soccer of soccer
and i think there was there was
something else like oh
i think there was a um like a a handball
but not the handle on the wall
there's a different kind of handball
that you throw into the net
so so it's called handball and um it's
it's it's a mixture between i do not
explain it it's a mixture between
i don't know basketball and dodgeball i
don't know
it's a really i played it once but it's
a it's a really fun sport
so it's it's so there's a net on both
sides a picture like like a net
a a soccer net but not as big as a
soccer net okay much smaller
right and you hold the ball what's the
ball
how big is the ball like a basketball
like a volleyball a volleyball okay and
and so
you you run around you pass it you pass
it and then there are lines
that you can't pass yeah and you have to
throw the ball
into the net it's called handball it's
it's
it's a european sport but it's it's
pretty cool so
and they had that sport so all these
kids will come
and you know we all live together and
yeah it was pretty it was pretty crazy
so how long were you at the school for
so i was two months there
and then i went from there i went
another month to a different part
of um germany to play with some
pros because uh this is this is
way before you did any kind of
competition right yeah yeah it's before
competition because this
is just my learning right and then i
played with some pros
and um and the reason i played the pros
was because
uh a year before or maybe not a year
maybe yeah maybe about a year before i
went to go see a competition
to see what it looked like and and and
where
uh it was in what was this competition i
think it was u.s open
and it might have been in las vegas okay
maybe no what's the
maybe maybe because of the guy so
the the guy who helped me so so he took
me to see a competition
and um there was uh players there who
were like
the best of in the world and they would
say oh that guy
is waldner he's the number one player in
the world and so like
i frankly didn't care who these guys
were i just wanna i'll go up there and
talk to them like yo
i heard you're number one all right
they'll look at me like i'm stupid
like yeah that's a rare that's a rare uh
a trait that a lot of new yorkers have
yeah you can talk to anybody talk to
anybody you're number one you're like
yeah
so so so i met some people there and
they always said
if you ever in germany
and you want to play you should let us
know so it just worked out like holy
[ __ ] i'm in [ __ ] germany
i i know some people so i i send you
know i contacted
uh a friend and i was like yeah i mean
germany hand over it and he was like oh
you should come to frankfurt
and i i really had no more money left
like it was crazy
and and i did i went there i went to i
went to uh to frankfurt and uh
hung out with a friend who plays
professional he played the german
national team
and uh then i went to then he brought me
to a smaller city which is called
uh grensel actually this this town
most germans don't even know this town
that's how small it's really small it's
called it's called grensall so so so
the the town everyone would know is
called koblins
coblins is a big city everyone knows
that if you go up in the city
if you go up into the mountains there's
a
another town called hergen's housing
hurricane's housing is a smaller town
then if you go with in that town it's
another town called grenzel
and it's a very very very small town
it's actually a table tennis town which
is crazy
everyone who lives there either plays
loves or likes table tennis
wow everyone so so it was really cool
for me to play there because
what's it called what's that little town
it's called grensall gren
sal g-r-e-n-s-a-l no i think
g-r-e-n-s-a-u
s-a-u grand sound okay and and it's a
very interesting place because
everyone there knows table tennis so for
me it was really cool
being a black dude from america who's
going to practice with this team because
everyone knew already
everyone knew oh there's a black guy
coming from america was that super rare
for them
it's yeah there's no extra how many
was there none at this time zero wow
yeah and it's very rare for them too
because
this team was the best team
in the world so so for example like uh
um
okay let's take soccer like soccer for
example
is the best team in table tennis as was
brazil
to soccer so they played champions
league this team never lost
so the fact that some american black guy
was coming to practice
everybody was like who's this dude like
is he good right i sucked i wasn't even
good
i was really good um so so i went there
to practice and
and that's why i spent the rest of my
time in germany really had
zero money like friends help help me out
because
the guys thing already ended right so
this was something now that was
pretty much on my own oh yeah because
because
because that that that thing was already
paid for it was for a certain amount of
time
and this was now me on my own so instead
of coming back today they were coming
back to the states yeah you just decided
to
i decided to to go to freaking to
grandson
to go how did you hear about grandson oh
because uh when i told you that from the
u.s open
the guy oh okay he said that if i'm in
germany
so i met him and he brought me there
and it was cool it was crazy man because
it was like the best players in the
[ __ ] world
on one team and it was nuts i would
watch them practice
and and they would play with me a little
bit of course i wasn't that level
right but uh the coach's son
was good and i played a lot with the
coach's son he also trained with the
team
he was an alternate for the team so i
i played with him a lot okay because he
was the closest one to
what my level was after training at that
school right
the other guys were top with top top top
players in the world
so of course i'm not that level but but
they would still play with me you know
because you know for them it was
interesting
some black american kid you know
practicing with them and they're the
best of the best of the best yeah so
so i stayed there for for about
another month and then i came back to
america